hello everyone welcome to the active
inference lab
we're here on august 17 2021
in live stream number 26.2
on
the second discussion that we're having
as a group on the paper bayesian
mechanics for stationary processes
welcome to the active inference lab
everyone we are a participatory online
lab that is communicating learning and
practicing applied active inference you
can find us at the links here on this
page
this is recorded in an archived live
stream so please provide us with
feedback so that we can improve on our
work
all backgrounds and perspectives are
welcome here and we'll be following
video etiquette for live streams so we
can use the raise hand feature in jitsi
this short link has the upcoming live
stream discussions
here we are on august 17th in our last
discussion on this paper 26.2 next week
we'll be heading into a new paper and we
still have some openings in the coming
weeks so if anyone has a suggestion or
an author to contact or wants to discuss
their own paper just let us know and we
can try to make that happen
today in acting stream number 26.2 the
goal is to continue learning and
discussing and unpacking this awesome
paper that we've been thinking about for
the last few weeks bayesian mechanics
for stationary processes and we're
really appreciative that the first
author is here to join with us and
co-learn with us have fun with us
and this video is just going to be
wherever we want to take it so we have
some questions prepared but especially
if anyone in the live chat has questions
that'd be awesome and we can definitely
address them
so we can just start with a quick
introduction round and feel free just to
say hello or to
answer one of these questions like
what's something that you liked or
remembered about the paper and what's
something that you're wondering about or
want to have resolved by the end of
today so i'm daniel i'm a postdoctoral
researcher in california
and
something that
over the last week
made me excited to
have this discussion was i was speaking
with a physicist friend someone who's
working with lasers and oscilloscopes
and stuff
and i brought up this paper
and they
it turned out that they actually were
using pid control
in their research on a day-to-day basis
but actually it was new for them to hear
about how it was connected to some of
these broader topics but as soon as i
brought out the physical printed paper
then they were just so excited and it
was cool to see how they had all this
practical
experience working with pid
and then they instantly just saw that
there was kind of this crossover point
into some broader questions that also
they were curious about but the
day-to-day practice actually hadn't
brought them to those general questions
so it was a and i learned a lot about
pid control and about actually how it
plays out with the knobs and everything
like that i'll pass to dean
yeah good morning um
yeah i
i came away from the paper again trying
to figure out
how to
create some sort of a coherent narrative
around
the the
physical math and the statistical math
that part for me
really got me going away and thinking a
little bit because i think they they go
in different directions but i do think
that they can work in concerts so
yeah i'd be really interested to see how
that
might play out in terms of
what what our
our guest here um
thinks the directions this might be able
to go i'll pass it to stephen
hello i'm stephen i'm based in toronto
um
i work a lot with
community development and uh sort of
spatial meaning making so inferences of
different kinds
i'm curious
how some of the
ways that the mathematics have been done
on this paper
can
help
broaden some of the questions around
ergodicity and non-ergodicity in uh
that's a bit of a thorn sometimes a
weapon
in the inactivist
active influence dialogue so um yeah any
and that's something i'll be interested
in and um i'm going to pass this over to
dave
so i think dave doesn't have audio but
dave thanks for joining and any
questions in the youtube live chat is
awesome so thanks
to everyone who's joined and passed to
lance
thanks daniel and thanks for inviting me
again
uh sam nance i'm a phd student at
imperial and ucl
and i'm really excited to be here and to
engage in this discussion
i'm really looking forward to
feedback about the paper seeing what's
interesting to to pursue in future work
um so yeah really looking forward to
to share this paper with you and and
talk about it
so maybe one lead-in question before we
jump to the content what stage in your
phd are you
and is this like the meat and potatoes
chapter one or is this um a little
cul-de-sac that you found yourself
having to explore
in the course of another research
project
um yeah great question so i'm right in
the middle of my phd i'm two years in to
still have two years to go
and um
ideally i would like to pursue this work
but so i have two supervisors one is a
mathematician
another one is a neuroscientist
and so really the the goal
is to is to have some kind of
mathematical theory of how adaptive
systems work so i think this is really
the the first chapter
i want to push that further
but then there are also other projects
that take up my time so i'm trying to
make all that work together
awesome
so
for this dot two we have some questions
prepared some topics that we know we to
talk about but anyone who asks a
question in a live chat will definitely
have
time to address that
the paper that we've been talking about
is this bayesian mechanics for
stationary processes paper and in the
dot zero and the dot one there's more
information on the primary aims and
claims so check those out if you haven't
already
we're just going to
take one more look at the road map
where we've been where we're going
remember we were talking about markov
blankets and basic mechanics how does
active inference have similarities and
differences from
other ways to model dynamical systems
and let's just go straight to the first
question that we have which is going to
help us
review where we've been and then also as
a jumping off point for some of these
extended questions that we've already
written
so a colleague asked me
and said i think it would be good to
expand on the differences of the
paradigms in section 3. and those are
section b c and d
related to a posteriori estimation after
the fact
predictive processing and variational
base so perhaps lance first and then
anyone else who wants to give a take or
ask a follow-up question
what are the similarities and the
differences here and why were they
structured in this order is this the
chronological order is this most
specific to least specific or what is
the ordering and the meaning here
right um
yeah so so the
it goes from the the simplest to the
most sophisticated
um so
uh adversary estimation is a special
case of predictive processing which is
specific
special case of variational base
and so the idea
is
if you
if you receive some piece of data so for
example if you see an image
um with your eyes you're gonna try to
infer what's going on
outside in the environment and so if you
do a posterior estimation
what you're trying to guess is what is
the most likely thing
um like what what is the most likely
thing that's going on in the environment
so it could be if you if you see an
image of a chair you you would say oh
it's a chair
but you wouldn't encode any any kind of
uncertainty oh it might be like an
armchair for example or something a bit
different so in a posterior estimation
you try to guess what's going on outside
but there's no uncertainty
then predictive processing you encode
the uncertainty so mathematically
that's called the variance or the ov
precision
and then variation of bayes it's uh it's
more sophisticated so you actually
encode
uh an arbitrary distribution
uh on external states um so it could be
oh it's very likely that it's an
armchair
and it might also be very likely that
it's a cat so that this example doesn't
make sense but you
you could imagine that there's two
things that are very different that
could be equally likely so for example
if you see an illusion it could be
something but also something very
different so you would imagine these two
things of having
a high probability of being there and
then other things are having low
probability
so this is really um
the the most general thing uh and also
as a side comment so rational base um
like a lot of machine learning
algorithms you can see them as special
cases of variational base so i think
this is really the most general way to
think about inference
and and this is really at the heart of
the free energy principle
and i think this is why people have been
describing the brain as performing
variation of base
because it's really the most general way
to think about this kind of problem of
inference
awesome well
before i give a comment on that what
made you say that it was at the heart of
the free energy principle
right
so the free energy principle
says that the brain is doing a
variational base
and and then all this work i mean this
paper in particular but like
um
the last decade people have been trying
to justify
why would the free energy principle
apply actually
um and so and so this is part of uh this
paper is part of a line of work where we
try to examine physical systems or like
adaptive systems and see whether we can
describe them as performing variational
base
great so first stephen with a question
and then anyone else with a question
thanks that's really helpful that
explanation and i was wondering
is it a case then that you can go only
so far with say predictive processing
um and then to get to variational bays
you could and to bring in that
uncertainty you kind of need a free
energy
principle solution to be able to bring
in these
more unknown models and
to go beyond variational bays at some
point that's when you'd have to bring in
the active inference
to
it would that be a kind of the way you
would think about it
yeah yeah we i would think about it like
this um
i would say uh like loosely speaking the
term predictive processing
i think is also meant uh to refer to
variational base but at least a
variational base that's like a proper
mathematical definition of what it is
and then predictive processing it's more
like oh we're predicting something so
it's not that clear how how
i mean there's no clear definition of
predictive processing uh but in this
paper predictive processing is meant as
predictive coding
as in like the papers by ryo and ballard
where they looked at the visual system
and then they looked at
neurons in the cortex as
forming predictions and
suppressing prediction errors
um so yeah um
if you if you only do predictive
processing in in this sense i i think
you're you're limited
and variational base and active
inference is really like the the next
generation because you can accommodate
all sorts of models
and um and yeah i don't i don't think it
i mean i i cannot see at least uh how
you would go beyond that
thank you so
dean with a raised hand and then anyone
else
no that's i was curious so
it seems like the math is able to
help us understand the difference
between something that's really highly
defined
so that kind of a posterior posteriori
and then the sort of the fuzzy
where the very old variational base part
sort of gives us something
a little more a little less defined in
terms of the edges
and so i was just curious
does the brain kind of go back and forth
to to some degree mathematically
speaking between that which is really
clear and really
has a hard edge mathematically and and
those things which statistically
seem to
distribute within the within the
parameter set
um
yeah i mean i think
all these three um like a posterior
estimation as well as variational base
there's uh displausible explanations for
how the brain would implement them okay
and so so the idea
the idea for um
variational base or predictive
processing is that so the brain would be
encoding some kind of uncertainty
and so in the literature
people say that the the mean firing rate
of a neural population
would encode the posterior estimates so
what you think is actually out there and
then the variance of the firing rates
would encode your uncertainty
so i think
so i think there's possible plausible
theories for how the brain would
implement all of these things
and then i think the that's the nice
thing at least with active inference is
that we try to develop models
that are consistent with our
understanding of the brain and as our
understanding of the brain evolves we
kind of like refine these models
um so so i think
we're definitely working towards uh
models
that that do explain at least i mean so
far it's very coarse grain and very
simplistic but we're working towards
models
that could be implemented in the brain
so i think like these um
very very abstract very general form of
variational base could be implemented in
the
brain one quick follow-up is you
mentioned how the mean firing rate
corresponds to this
first
a posteriority estimation which is a
mean estimation and then there's the
variance in the firing rate so what
measurements or what does it look like
to implement variational bays in the
brain like what measurements are we
making what kinds of analyses would we
make on those just like mean and
variance
um
well so so the idea i mean the very
simple idea is that you would get some
sensory stimulus so
you you get some some impression on your
retina
uh some neurons in your retina with fire
uh into the into the visual cortex and
then um
the the the premise is that your brain
has
embodies them
a generative model of its environment so
so it's able
it has learned how to recognize uh how
to how to infer things in the
environment from its sensations
and so the
the stimulus that would be that would go
into into v1 and all these other parts
of visual cortex
and then the neurons in in the visual
cortex would uh
align their means firing rates with
respect to oh it's an armchair or it's
something different
um so maybe there's a neural population
that encores armchair and there's a
neural population that encodes something
else
there's also a lot of studies for
specific neurons like one neuron
encoding one particular stimulus
so these um there's these guys at mit
that show that there's actually a bill
clinton neuron uh that fires whenever
you see bill clinton so you can be very
specific
and um and yeah but if it's uncertain
that it's bill clinton your
your bill clinton neuron would like fire
yeah i guess would have a lot of
variance in its firing rate
okay awesome so welcome
blue with a raised hand go for it and
then um we'll continue and also steven
so go ahead blue
um i am blue knight and i'm an
independent research consultant from new
mexico and i have a question on your
paper and it's kind of something that
i've been questioning a lot lately with
regards to
the free energy principle and the
requirement for ergodicity
um and my question is um in your paper
you said that the um
you know this the outline even in
outline it says you know you you
partition the world with the markov
blanket and then you equip the partition
with stochastic dynamics and so i'm
wondering how these stochastic dynamics
relate to organicity if at all
and if that fulfills the requirement for
um ergonomy as
necessary by the fbp
right yeah that that's a great question
um yeah i think i think stephen also
also wanted to talk about that so it's
great that you bring this up
um
so
yeah so so the idea of these stochastic
dynamics is that we don't assume that
dynamics are deterministic and it makes
sense because
um you can describe planets as having
deterministic dynamics but when you talk
about biological systems
things are a lot more messy and if
you're not
modeling them at the molecular level
which you which you never are
things are stochastic
so then the the assumption on our system
is is that it's stationary
and this is really what it means to to
be adaptive so you're preserving some
kind of steady state
but we never assume ergodicity
so there's actually um a deep um
so stationary and ergodicity are not the
same so we assume
stationarity but we don't assume
ergodicity and so if daniel you could go
to the appendix b
there's um there's a figure i think
which would be the best way to
to illustrate a bit below
yeah perfect
so
um
here in this appendix we
we illustrate uh some dynamics that are
ergodic and some dynamics that are not
ergotic
so
if you if you look at the
uh top left top and bottom left panels
these dynamics are ergotic and and so
the
i guess the intuitive definition of
ergodicity
is that
here you have the the steady state in
blue so so regions that are very blue
are regions of high probability mass
under the state state of regions where
you
your dynamic is likely to be in and
regions are less blue
you're less likely to be in
now ergodicity means that if you start
your dynamic anywhere
and you and you let it run for a
sufficient amount of time so like you
observe your biological system for a
very long time
um your dynamic would basically sample
the whole distribution it would go
i mean if you if you give it enough time
it would go really far away
and then it will come back and it will
do all sorts of things as you can see in
the bottom left and bottom right
um so this is ergotic now in the
in the in the bottom oh no in the top
left and and bottom left it's it's
ergotic and then the
bottom right it's not ergotic
and so
um so as you can see if you start the
dynamic on the bottom right anywhere
it will go around an orbit they won't
sample the whole distribution so it's
still confined to like a
a small region
and and so this this uh so the the paper
still applies for these kind of dynamics
um
see i don't i don't know does that help
or do you
or was that
not very clear it's so such a follow-up
the paper does apply in
situations where it's not
that's what you said right right we yeah
we don't need aerodynacity well so even
within like a steady state
um like so biological systems you know
operate
within homeostasis but it's a range
right so so it's not
like a constant it's not like you know
purely we're not at 37 degrees all the
time right like so there's some
fluctuation all the time within that
steady
state and and so i just want to kind of
how you rectify those concepts like is
it like a restricting of the the state
space or or how does that work
um
so so the this idea of homeostasis
that's that's really the the steady
state assumption
so for example um
in the state space maybe you would have
one one uh one coordinate that describes
the temperature of your
of your biological system
and if it's a human um
then you will have regions of very high
probability so here regions in blue
around 37 degrees and then regions that
are less blue
uh like a bit further away
uh and so the dynamic
i mean your your system can evolve in in
all of these regions just like on
average you will be more often around 37
degrees just because that's how we are
and then but sometimes it will be higher
and sometimes it will be lower and and
so this is all allowed
um and so i guess the this ergodicity
assumption so then if you assumed
that the biological system was ergodic
then this would imply that if you if you
leave the biological system
like run for a sufficiently long time
like you observe it for a very long time
it will basically um
it will sample your whole distribution
of temperatures
um
so so maybe
so so
maybe like the the temperature that
um a human body is allowed to have are
between like 36 and 39 let's just say
for for simplicity and so ergodicity
would say
um yeah if i if i observed my biological
system for a sufficiently long time
i would see my biological system at all
these temperatures
and i think maybe
maybe that would happen so maybe our uh
maybe temperature is like uh
we're ergotic with respect to
temperature but maybe there's other
things in which we aren't ergotic
and um
and i think the the previous papers on
the free energy principle they
for simplicity they always took like um
they always assumed some kind of dynamic
and it turned out to be ergotic
and so in here we we're not making that
assumption
so
i'm sorry i'm going to just follow with
one more question daniel is that okay
yeah um
so so
you know it's great right if you're
talking about one human system right
like my mark on blanket the partitions
like internal and external states and so
i have my one human system or even
multiple human systems like we will
operate in the same kind of steady state
based range but but if we're talking
really about um you know collections and
how kind of
collective dynamics and overlapping
markup blankets
do you think it's mathematically
possible to extend the state space like
i can operate you know from 36 to 39
that's an okay temperature for me but
like a reptile has a very different kind
of temperature range but clearly like we
have some interaction i have interaction
with the reptile and so there's some
some emergent dynamic between me and
some reptile future right right like so
can we define a state space like would
it be mathematically like
acceptable or is it like offensive
mathematically like
impossible to
define a state space where i'm allowed
to sample all of these temperature
ranges with my markup blanket but some
other feature in some kind of collective
dynamics is not like they have a
different range like is that still
organicity because it's not clearly i'm
not sampling the entire state space i'm
sampling my state space but like is that
confounding in some way i mean it is in
my brain that's why i'm asking yeah that
that's a really good question um so so
this is all fine so so we can do
everything you just said
and so when we um so actually when
when we say oh we so we we always sample
a distribution
we're not i mean and then the
distribution is on the safe space so
we're sampling the state space
but like if your distribution is
confined to a region of state space so
let's say
as a human um i cannot possibly have any
bodily temperatures below 36 degrees
then your then you would sample only
things are above 36 degrees
um so i think you would have your own uh
steady state your own stationary
distribution with temperatures around 37
degrees and then if there's a if there's
a snake also in the in this environment
that you're modeling then we'll have a
another very different steady state
and so
i think it really
uh your question really speaks to the
possible extensions of these of this
work
because in this paper we just say oh
there's like an internal state space
which would be what's inside
and then there's an external state space
which would be what's outside
but then um
really what what people would need to do
now is to say oh but my
actually there's a lot of very
interesting things in my environment
there may be snakes there may be
other kinds of animals and they all have
their own markov blanket and they all
have their own steady state so then what
you can do is to partition your external
state space into all of these things
that might be around you
and then instead of having
some kind of um
performing some kind of
simple inference as we have in this
paper you would have some more structure
inference a more structured inference
because part of your inference would be
about
what's just in front of you part of your
inference would be about your dog that's
right over there and you would have a
lot of
by carving your external state space
into different things with their own
steady state
you would actually have a an inference
that's much more structured because you
would infer all these things all these
different things that are in your
environment
so this can all be accommodated in this
paper
but then you would definitely need
another paper to like make that explicit
and
and say some really interesting things
because yeah this is really um the way
to go but the the mathematics doesn't
need doesn't need extension it's just
like um
yeah it would just be like partition the
state space and then yeah we can have
all that that you spoke about
thank you
great and also one piece so then
stephen's question is it's it's not as
if something being ergodic or not is
equivalent to it being easy or simple or
tractable like looking at these
distributions um or trajectories here
the one that you characterized as
non-ergotic not sampling um basically
across the state space the bottom right
this one
is the one that in the caption it says
purely conservative dynamics lower right
panel are reminiscent of the
trajectories of massive bodies whose
random fluctuations are negligible
so it's actually not like it's um maybe
this will speak to steven's questions
about what is a thorn and and what's a
rose
because this is a non-ergotic system
that's
massively predictable
you can do it with a you know a gear
so
maybe that relates to
some of these criticisms about well
we're only working with a limited set of
ergotic processes it's like okay but
that's the squiggly one that's dancing
everywhere the stochastic process that
we care about whereas including
non-ergotic processes some of these
non-organic processes might just be
going around in an oval so it won't be a
challenge for the math at all something
that works on the stochastic squiggle is
going to have actually an easier time on
this oval one so
stephen and then anyone else with a
question
yeah thanks um
yeah i suppose actually tying into what
you just said there daniel the
that there's this question with um
how much we
need to be able to sample over big state
spaces so it might well be that i don't
know the chemicals of a cell there
with molecules vibrating
millions of times a second and
there may be a you know a quick
ongoing way to sort of get a feel for
the ergodic state space
now if you watch a
cricket ball come towards you
um
you know you don't get that chance to do
that so but you might want to sort of
maintain a trajec some sort of
trajectory
um that can still be um
tractable i suppose so
i think this is this is actually quite
quite useful
um i suppose the question then comes in
is
how what's the sort of in-betweens you
know where does
um approximation science come in more
and more
to allow us to sort of
work with not knowing
um and work with something like um these
solenoidal flows
um
in a more fuzzy way um
because i am assuming that if you've got
less chances to sample your state space
solenoidal might be
more useful
to get towards something tractable or
maybe i'm wrong but i wonder what your
thoughts are on that
right um so actually solenoidal um
i mean so
in in this figure here uh on the bottom
left you have like
no solenoidal flow and then the bottom
right there's just so the node or flow
um so i would say
all of these two like very special cases
uh they don't look like biological
systems at all
and they're also the the simplest ones
to to understand mathematically and to
study mathematically
and actually when it gets really
interesting and when it looks a lot more
like a biological system is on the top
left
and that's harder to
to assess mathematically um
and so as you can see it's quite i mean
i think the dynamic on the top left is
quite nice because on the one hand you
have dissipation like you have some
squiggly lines you have randomness
on the other hand thanks to the
solenoidal flow you have some kind of
exploration
and also some kind of like circular
patterns so for example in um
and this is actually how how you correct
there is what's called a non-equilibrium
steady state but without without going
into the details
um as humans as and as animals we have a
lot of circular patterns they are not
purely deterministic so for example we
all have a circadian rhythm
um and we all have all sorts of other um
yeah circular patterns and i think
yeah to account for that uh you really
need to be to be on the top left
um so i think the
[Music]
i mean one of the next steps to this
research is
right right now we just assumed that the
dynamic is stationary and so all this
applies to like a humongous
range of dynamics and a lot of them
don't look like biological systems at
all
and i think the next step would be to
to restrict ourselves to dynamics that
look a lot more like that like
biological systems
and then see what what else can we say
and and i bet there's some dynamics that
look a lot like very intelligent systems
and some that also look like maybe
lifelike systems but they are not so
intelligent so the question is what kind
of parameters what kind of dynamics do
you need
um to characterize something that
explores its environment uh something
that makes decisions and all sorts of
things
um
yeah
and and that's going to be a challenge
and also
i mean just speaking about biological
systems i think biological systems have
a lot of solenoidal flow and they do
have dissipation but they don't have so
much dissipation
so you would have something like the top
left but with like huge
you have huge like a lot of expiration
like you would go a lot further than
that in your state space
and then you would have a bit of i mean
you would have a lot of squiggly lines
but
it would be yeah there would be a lot
more like exploration than there is
dissipation
yes stephen go forward
yeah and and
you have both can combine can't so
gradient
sin and solenoidal flow can kind of
be playing at the same time i'm
wondering if someone was to bring
attention to a goal or a type of
attention maybe more pragmatic attention
or an epistemic attention or a risk
adverse attention
whether
it might be that rather than trying to
deal with the whole state space maybe
that that general
process carries on but in it tries to
introduce a solenoidal
you know um type of flow which in some
ways you could imagine being more
tractable to a biological system if it's
like bioelectricity
um there's you know the types of
dynamics which may be are more
tractable around a certain trajectory um
than some
um so you've the these the these
dynamics could combine
um
in different regimes of attention
yeah
yeah definitely um
and i think but i think to to properly
account for attention we we need to go
beyond these continuous state spaces
and do what people um
um and basically extend to these
standard models of active inference
where in in addition to have some
continuous state space maybe like for
movements and this kind of thing you
also have a discrete state space
and then you would have a dynamic
evolving in your discrete state space
and maybe like
some state would be oh i'm attending
over there and some other state would be
unattending over there so i think
attention is really something
um that can be modeled
with a discrete state space
um
and then it would
i don't think it would be so hard and i
mean at least seems doable to extend all
the math here to like models
uh yeah that have some like continuous
state space maybe for movement or
or
or other kinds of things like maybe like
blood glucose concentration is also
something that evolves on a continuous
scale there's also a lot of a lot of
things in our mind that are discrete so
is this red yes or no
is it raining yes or no
and to account for all that we need uh
we need a discrete state space as well
awesome thank you lance welcome scott i
see your hand raised so go for the
question and then anyone else with a
raised hand
thank you i came in a little late um my
apologies is fascinating the solenoidal
flow when that gets set up
is it possible that he had multiple
state spaces and
might because of the solenoidal flow
might it have a periodicity in each of
the state spaces so that you might be
able to use fourier transforms to unpack
multiple state spaces in a biological
system
so could you use
having that periodicity does that allow
for a fourier type analysis to start to
unpack state spaces potentially when you
have multiple state spaces and you're
trying to distinguish them
yeah that's a that's a really good point
so i know um
i know a paper actually that that
analyzes the solenoidal flow in terms of
the fourier transform
um i haven't really really thought about
it i think i mean if if you get rid of
the dissipative part so if you get rid
of the squiggly lines and you're just in
the bottom right
then you can definitely use fourier
transforms
but then also the dynamic on the bottom
right is not is not representative of
biological systems
um
so then what you can do when you're on
the top left which is really the
interesting case
is analyze the time irreversible part so
the solenoid will flow with the fourier
transform
and then so you so you do this hem holes
decomposition that we're talking about
in the appendix
uh you decompose your dynamic into
yeah so it's the equation a2
um
yeah yeah perfect so you decompose your
uh your drift b so so b is the direction
in which your dynamic is moving um on
average into reversible and irreversible
parts the irreversible part is the
solenoid overflow which you can analyze
using fourier transform
but then you need to like figure out how
to accommodate the reversible part with
it
so i can share i can share the paper
um
if you're interested but yeah it seems
like like they're they're able to to
like do do some things with that
technique uh but it's also pretty pretty
involved to be honest
a question on the time reversible and
irreversible
what does that mean and in a world where
it seems like we're moving forward
through time only what exactly does that
mean that there's something that's
invariant under time reversible
versus something that changes sign under
time reversal like if we can't
get the time machine or put the process
in a time machine why does it matter
that it's time reversible or how does
that fall out of the equations
right um
well yeah so so
all this is really to emphasize that
we're not assuming the dynamic to be
time reversible
and and as you say everything in the
world around us i mean most things are
time irreversible so
the
uh if you go back to the to the figure
just below so the movement of planets is
really something that's irreversible i
mean the the earth turns around the sun
in one direction and if you are to
rewind time
it will turn around the sun in the other
direction so that
so in this case you can really tell the
difference between
time as time goes forward and as time
goes backward and that's really what's
meant by time irreversible
um but now if you look like a other cup
of coffee
and the coffee is still
um the the
molecules the
coffee molecules or whatever molecules
you have in that cup they're still
bouncing with each other
and that's that's something that's time
reversible because if you look at the
cup of coffee um if you if i give you a
movie of the cup of coffee sitting still
you can watch the movie uh as time goes
forward or backward and uh and you
wouldn't be able to tell the difference
so that's something that's reversible
and so as you can see from this example
actually things that are reversible
aren't interesting at all
from at least a biological perspective
and there's a there's so much literature
about
um yeah about one of the
uh i mean one of the fundamental things
of being alive
is being time irreversible
it's about like eating and producing
waste um it's about yeah consuming
energy
all that kind of thing all that kind of
stuff um produces entropy and is time
irreversible
um but then time so time irreversibility
it's something that's necessary to be
alive
but it's not it's not sufficient
um so for example if i give you
um a convection cell
though that would be time irreversible
but it won't it won't be alive
so any any kind of cycle that's more or
less periodic um so maybe if you if you
see like a cyclone
a cyclone is time irreversible because
it's like
spinning one way and not the other so if
you run out of time it would be spinning
the other way
so it's different so it's time
irreversible but that's not alive
um and so
there's many
many things like that time
irreversibility um
yeah creation of entropy
there's a few things like that that
characterize biological systems
and i think as we as we go on with this
work we'll we'll try to like specialize
to only those dynamics that
satisfy all these requirements and
eventually things like oh we need
systems that are able to reproduce for
example like a marker blanket that is
able to divide into two markup blankets
for example when a when a cell
decomposes into
into two cells so
so this is really the beginning and
and yeah in the next years i think this
community is really
going to be able to
to like address all these challenges and
like
um
all these characterizations of living
systems to to gradually evolve towards
models that are
yeah more realistic i would say
awesome
so
i'll have more to say on it but scott go
for it
so a couple of things there's a book
called life's ratchet which is kind of
interesting just on that um the idea of
that irreversibility and that value of
that the idea is that life kind of
ratchets in these forms that work with
the externality i haven't revisited that
since i've been exposed to active
inference but it might be interesting to
take another look at life's ratchet also
one of the things i
like that discussion of living forms and
what's necessary uh prerequisites to
living forms one of the working
definitions i'll share that i'm using
now
and i think let me tell you why i'm
using it is um that life is auto
catalytic
and entropy secreting
now my kids claim the i just wanted to
say secretion in my definition because
it's gushy that was my my kids used to
say but um
auto catalytic and entropy secreting so
notice i didn't say it had to be
embodied in a specific form or specific
matrix or context it could be a market
it could be a markov you know a lot of
different things so um
so the reason i share that here it's
interesting because active inference we
have this definition of life like
corollas linnaeus you look at it you see
if it has feathers and you see if it has
blood and stuff like that but now we're
going towards mathematical definitions
of living things
and that's going to be very interesting
because i think what when we have a
working definition that works for
biologic forms so again my working
definition right now is auto catalytic
and entropy secreting
um then i can start to say okay
if that works for biologic forms let's
say that did work and maybe there's
problems with whatever but if it works
then you can start saying okay what
other systems happen to be auto
catalytic and entropy secreting and
therefore we shall now call living
and maybe we can start to look at them
and make observations about those
systems and what i'm thinking about i'm
a guy who's a lawyer and in finance for
years so i'm looking at this and saying
okay you look at these systems
biological systems came up with these
markets and these other
systems that we have to do things in the
world maybe these systems are
describable with biological framings and
so that's why the kind of work you're
doing feels like it as it starts to
reveal some more general definitions of
living forms taking those definitions
and then reapplying them back out into
the world and saying okay
are there living forms that have escaped
our detection as living forms and
basically are they is there scale
independence are there fractal elements
what are the things that we can now
describe in those things that we
previously had not thought of as biology
but in fact are describable as biology
that's very exciting to me so i just
wanted to say that the kind of things
you were describing there and that kind
of working way back down into a model of
life based on time irreversibility it's
very interesting i think thanks and very
interesting paper overall i'm looking
forward to
diving into this and the other that
other paper you were mentioning also
thank you cool yeah
yeah thanks a lot that that's really
great
so to tie this
from the some of the physical examples
we've been talking about like the
diffusion processes
to the
physics of information and information
flows
the big thing we've been talking about
is this statistical
physics and this bayesian mechanics
and we heard a little bit earlier how we
could talk about the moments like the
first moment the simplest form the a
posteriori estimation was the mean and
then the second moment of a statistical
distribution is the variance and there's
also higher statistical moments that
describe higher and higher aspects of an
informational distribution
there's also the concept in physics of
moments like the position and the
velocity in higher and higher physical
moments
and so the mapping is that potentially
these physical moments that would
describe components of a physical flow
that could also be decomposed using the
helmholtz decomposition might also apply
to some of these
informational
flows and decompositions so we could
use those analogies like the the coffee
mixing and the steady state of the
coffee and then think about how a
statistical distribution is playing by
similar rules
and so it's also interesting scott about
instead of going from the um non-living
systems and then looking for that
pattern and pattern matching to
biological systems we can kind of start
up on the top left with or something
even more biologically fleshed out and
then look for those patterns and pattern
match
outside of systems that have you know a
vertebra and a central nervous system
because that shouldn't be the um
the card to get into the club of
information processing systems
or entropy secreting systems so
any thoughts lance
[Music]
yeah i mean
yeah i think i think that's that's
really interesting um
i mean the the the real challenge here
is to is to make the link between the
physics and the information
and
the the more i've been working on this
the more i realized that actually a lot
of a lot of physics or at least a lot of
statistical physics you can
um you can explain with properties of of
information
so for example
entropy increasing is also
information being lost
um
not not
stochasticity
stochasticity so the inability to
predict the future exactly and
it is exactly the same as
entropy being lost over time
information being lost over time and
entropy entropy increasing
so i think there's um
there's very deep connections between um
yeah information physics
uh inference
and uh so some of them have been fleshed
out but not
i mean it hasn't it hasn't really been
put together at least as far as i know
in this context in the context of markov
blankets
in the context of how how can we
like have a theory of how adaptive
systems work
and
can we describe adaptive systems as
performing imprints
um so so i think this is this is really
exciting
and and also as you can see from this
paper so the
the dynamics that we're considering
there they're extremely general
and for these dynamics for all of them
were able to derive some kind of
inference so this is to say that this uh
inferential description
is it applies to many systems
and so it means that on the one hand
it's very ubiquitous but then on the
other hand it's not it's not that useful
because
um
maybe like uh the things that didn't
look at all like biological systems
can still can still satisfy this kind of
uh free energy principle or bayesian
mechanics
so so i think what's really exciting is
to
to be able to
um in in the future to to like
specialize to those dynamics that look
more like biological systems and then
really look at these informational
properties
and i think a big one is
how much exploration do we have
and exploration is really something
exploration and curiosity it's really
something that characterizes uh
intelligent systems as we know it
and um
and yeah so there's some discussions in
in the literature of how we would be
able to use things like uh
information length and concepts for
information theory and information
geometry to quantify things like memory
and itinerancy curiosity and so on
so one question from the live chat
before you continue the question is what
is the explicit definition of
information flow and also maybe in that
if you want to describe a little bit
about this other
paper like what is information flow
what is information geometry and how
does it relate to what we're talking
about here
right um so so this
this is all the idea of um
as as an organism you're always encoding
some beliefs about your environment so
we talked about maximum posteriori and
variational inference
so the idea is that we're always
receiving sensations and then making
some inferences about the outside
now if you're making some inferences
about the outside
implicitly or mathematically you're
parameterizing a distribution
about things in the in the environment
and so information geometry uh then
comes into play uh information geometry
quantifies the extent to which beliefs
about the environment are different from
each other
um
so it doesn't it doesn't make sense so
for example
let's say that um
i think uh daniel's um
yeah uh daniel's uh eyes are blue
let's let's just say
um
and then i have some uncertainty around
the real color
um so that would be like one
one kind of uh belief i could hold and
then another type of belief would be
daniel's eyes
um
are brown and then i would have some
other kind of uncertainty
now the way um
now a question you could ask me is how
different are these two beliefs
um and if you have a if i had a
different belief about the color of his
eyes
would that believe be more different
than the beliefs i initially had
um so then information
geometry enables you to answer these
questions it enables you to say how how
two beliefs are different from each
other
uh by quantifying the distance between
them
but also even more interestingly
as i
um let's say i i've never met daniel
before let's say i haven't seen his
picture before now you give me a picture
of daniel
um i'm gonna make an inference about the
color of his eyes so from being
initially completely agnostic
i'm going to move my completely agnostic
belief to a belief that says oh maybe he
has
brown eyes
so this is to say that as we make
inferences and sample the world our
beliefs evolve and so information
geometry enables you to say um how it
enables you to quantify how much your
beliefs evolved evolved and what kind of
trajectory did they take
because i i mean i'm assuming at least
our beliefs uh they they evolve in a
continuous manner
as we sample more information
and then it becomes interesting to see
uh what kind of trajectories did my
beliefs take and was that was that
trajectory efficient uh if it wasn't
efficient maybe um i lost some energy
there that i could have used somewhere
else
so so
my my inference wasn't very optimal from
that perspective
and then so there's a paper about this
actually uh on active inference that
uses information geometry to to see how
how um whether inferences in active
inference are efficient from a metabolic
point of view so something that you can
look at with information geometry
thanks just to follow up from the chat
and then we'll return to our colleagues
here do we have
um or more precisely do we hope to have
a definition like an electromagnetic
flux in field theory
for information flows information flux
yes um
yes so so information flux is the
the movement of beliefs
and so you can
you can write that down mathematically
um
so so yeah i mean
a belief is a probability distribution
about things that are going on in the
environment
and as you sample information you would
change probability distribution so it'd
be like a motion
on the space of probability
distributions that's really the the
meaning of information flow but maybe
the question was about um can we derive
some kind of like maxwell's equation
some kind of law
about how um
about how information flow happens like
maybe an equation for information flow
and i would say that that's what we
that that would be the aim uh that would
be what what people are working towards
in theoretical neuroscience like some
kind of equation
that explains how we make inference
awesome
so a few raised hands scott first then
blue then stephen so go ahead scott a
couple of things that was fascinating
little bits there um so on that last
piece on the information for those two
points um the embodiment i'm thinking of
embodiment of information so i'm
thinking of a farmer that's deciding
what crops to plant so they look and
they get information from the newspaper
and they look at weather reports and
they gather information then they decide
on what seeds to plant the seed itself
is an embodiment of information they put
the seed in the ground they get results
with their farming the markets then
respond so there was there were seeds as
information farmers processing
information markets processing
information and one of the things that's
kind of interesting here it's a lot of
the work i'm doing now is in food chains
and trying to figure out how to de-risk
food chains and and just food generally
and
that efficiency question you just asked
is really interesting what are the
losses and conversions that happen when
information is embodied in those
different aspects of that decision
process through which something gets
converted from a need of society to have
a certain amount of corn at a certain
time of year
to through all those chains of seeds and
selections and farmers and processing
all those things it's kind of
interesting to look at the system as
both each piece of it is living the seed
is arguably living although there's a
question of where the seeds are living
among
people who are biologists but anyway
and then uh because they're not actively
doing stuff but the they're kind of
stasis but um anyway that embodiment
question is that's one and let me ask
i'll ask both and then turn off my voice
here so the embodiment question is one
kind of that notion you just talked
about about an overall formula maybe
there's an overall embodiment
characterization that's made possible
using those landscapes and looking at
kind of a multi-faceted landscape and
looking at those conversions that happen
from one embodiment of information to
another and efficiencies there that's an
interesting kind of possible thought the
other one is you said something about
curiosity before maximum exploration
maximum curiosity
that really struck me because one of the
things we've been advocating for i do
did a lot of cyber work a number of
years ago and people were coming out of
the military and we were saying oh hey
you ex-military guy you got to learn
more critical thinking and that was kind
of insulting because they were senior
people right they're like hey we can
work pretty quickly but really they
didn't and one of the things i started
saying is don't tell people they have to
have critical thinking that's not
consulting how they have to be more
curious
and it's kind of interesting that we're
getting now to these systems having a
maximum
exploration possibility a maximum
efficiency in some ways with curiosity
to me that really informs a lot of
teaching because if you have people who
develop a curiosity over their lifetime
they take care of being educated they
continuously are learning and so that
notion of exploration and curiosity
seems like it could fundamentally
through active inference
affect how we do teaching and much less
of rote teaching and much more of a
curiosity based teaching because of the
power you'll never know what you're
going to encounter out there in the
world and so telling your children hey
be curious will intrinsically serve them
versus teaching them a rote series of
things to respond to their environment
so just a couple of comments on those
last two things i thought were
fascinating thank you
yeah that that's really interesting um
so as you said and i think we all agree
i mean
information um
or maybe 70 70 years ago or 80 years ago
we didn't have any kind of information
theory information theory wasn't a thing
computers weren't the thing and we
didn't really think about information
even though it was there in books i mean
i mean everywhere around us and i think
with the
advent of computers and information
theory
um
just information became a big thing and
people realized that it was important
and
now everyone
thinks about everything in terms of
information and and i think that's the
the right way to
to look at things i mean it seems to be
um yeah information can encode just
about anything by
by definition
um and so physics uh or at least our
descriptions of the world they're
they um
matter was the most important thing
matter and and waves uh this is how
it all started
and then um
and then information geometry and
information theory came into play and
people started looking at these things
in terms of uh information as well
but i think mata uh remained the big
thing
um
but more and more people are looking at
at information in terms of like the
the most important concept at least the
the root concept from which uh from
which you can like encode or explain
everything else
and um
[Music]
so so yeah information geometry came
around and it enables you to to see how
how information is flowing over time and
how that relates to heat and
things like that
and now
people are looking at how information
may be encoded by things about other
things
and this is really basic mechanics based
in mechanics the the root of the word is
beliefs about things that are held
uh that are held by other things
and i think this is um
yeah i mean basic mechanics
i guess started out i mean in a way it
started out long ago with like basic
imprints
um
but but uh bayesian inference started
out as a as an abstract uh statistical
concept and now people are trying to
relate that to to physics
um
and yeah so so i think we're moving
towards the physics that's information
based and
uh and based about uh yeah based about
beliefs about things
encoded about other things so this is
really basic mechanics information
geometry
um
and then what you said about curiosity
was also really interesting
and
so so yeah definitely i mean in ai uh
people are tuning curiosity so
um yeah they're trying to optimize
curiosity of agents with respect to
different environments
in uh in a paper that we have
called active entrance on discrete state
space is a synthesis
we uh in in one of the appendices we we
justify the expected free energy
objective that people use for uh to
explain decision making in
biological agents
and we actually show that
we could have so the expected free
energy for for those who don't know
is basically ways exploration and
exploitation so exploration is really
the curiosity
so it has these two terms
and in general i mean these two terms
are put on the same footing
but actually in the in the appendix of
that
active inferences synthesis paper we
show that you could um weigh them in a
different way
and and it would
and i mean the
yeah the agent would still work somehow
but it will have a different behavior so
you could be a lot more curious or a lot
less curious
and that would be really interesting to
quantify in terms of like uh concepts of
information geometry
but so so this is to say that that you
can actually tune that and have agents
that have different curiosities
and also make me think about
what you said about things from
computational psychiatry
where um
people explain
diseases
like computational diseases as um
as people having like different priors
in their genetic model
um
and seeing how that how that would
affect behavior so you can
explain like sub-optimal optimal and
sub-optimal behavior with like the same
principles just by changing the model
and we also have um a recent paper on
the bayesian brains and the rainy
diversions where but we're basically
showing that by changing
doing variational inference a bit
differently
you can actually um account for for
agents that are optimal that make like
the right decisions and agents that
maybe are a bit sub-optimal in terms of
curiosity and
and so on so i think there's a
like a lot of exciting computational
work to be done
in terms of characterizing different
behaviors
and i think we're really at the
beginning and ultimately all these
things
will be able to i mean people will be
able to account for the information
geometry i think that's the right
framework
thank you lance just quick follow-up
scott go for it yep quick follow two
things when the beijing mechanics when
you say beliefs about things that are
held by other things that feels nice
with my example of the farmer and the
seeds
because it's an embodiment each thing
that embodies something is the
embodiment is a belief in a sense right
because it's holding a seed doesn't have
a belief itself but it's embodying
information
and so
it's interesting to think about belief
of things and then the embodiment of
information in the thing intrinsic
affordance that the thing offers right
that is that what's the relationship
between belief and intrinsic physical
affordance that's in in a system that is
the result of an earlier information
system that's one follow-up then the
second follow-up is the way i soften
people up when you talk to older people
and you're like oh it's all information
it's not physical we're information
beings the way i soften them up just to
share is i say to them do you have a
401k or retirement plan most older
people are starting to think about that
and then they they say yeah and i say do
you think it's a pile of groceries
waiting for you to retire because it's
not it's just data in a system and if
that system goes away you got nothing so
it's that idea of getting people to
understand how much we depend upon
information and then people start
thinking oh wow i guess i really do
depend upon all sorts of other systems
in my life it's a something that
as physical beings it's hard for us to
realize how much we are information
beings and that's again just part of
that rhetorical exercise to get people
in a head space of saying wow maybe
things really are information that i
thought were solid like my retirement
plans but really they're just totally
dependent on systems and the information
output of those systems thanks nice
scott thank you
so um blue with a question go for it
so you mentioned a paper um that you
well i don't know if it was your paper
but about information geometry and
activated friends is it this one that's
markup blankets information geometry and
stochastic thermodynamics is that the
paper you're talking about uh no that
that's not this one so here uh if you're
referring to the one um
yeah about how um inference is efficient
like quantifying efficiency of inference
and how much like energy
um you need to do a kind of inference um
so that's not this paper
it's another paper called uh neural
dynamics
under active
inference um something like that
so i um have some questions and i don't
know anything about information geometry
i mean just a little tiny bit um so it's
something that i'm definitely starting
to get very interested in because i
think that um
it's gonna
be maybe like the next level of where
active inference goes maybe maybe i mean
i just have this suspicion so when um
when you have information and in an
information geometry like in an
information flow
uh i've been reading other papers about
information flow in channels right so
like when you and i mean it makes sense
because when you have when you know
something about the current state i mean
it's just like an inference like you
your belief about the next state of the
world is based on
the state of the world right now right
so
i mean it doesn't make sense that you
would think you know all of a sudden i'm
going to be like on pluto
based on my current information and so
it does is information geometry or do
the channels appear when you look at
inference in information geometry like
does it appear to be like a trajectory
um
that's a good that's a good question
so i think i think information geometry
is is more general like you don't need
to have a channel it's it's really about
um
at the heart of it it's really about
having different probability
distributions and these are actually
beliefs about stuff
and looking how they differ from each
other and like movement
uh how how um
probability distributions change over
time these kind of problems
um but then um so so you're right to say
that information theory started out with
the study of channels
communication channels between different
uh different things
um and you have a
yeah there's a lot of work uh on
information theory and channels and
still today with uh in engineering
um so
i would i would guess there's a lot of
work also on information geometry with
channels
but that would be like um a subset of
the whole field of information geometry
and i would say it's uh it would be
yeah i would say the people contributing
to that literature would be mostly from
the um from engineering or around
engineering
thanks blue anything there yeah go for
it yeah if i could just follow really
quick so the um
so i know like about information theory
and like the flow of information in the
channel say like a telephone line or you
know whatever like
some direct method of communication but
like the way i i don't know i don't know
if i'm thinking about it in the wrong
way because when i try to search for
like information flow in a channel
um and maybe it's the same but i think
about it in a different way like i think
about the channel flowing from
like the present into the future
right so like there's only so many like
next states that are possible right like
based on my present state and so is it
is it incorrect or is it correct to
think about like not a direct channel as
in i'm speaking to you over this
internet information channel but like
the channel from now into some future
state is that the same kind of like
mathematical engineering information
channel
right um yeah that um yeah you're
catching me off guard because i don't i
don't know about channels
um so i mean what you say sounds sounds
possible and i would say yes
but i wouldn't be able to say for sure
just because i don't know that
literature
thanks well
i'm sure come back to this in the
weeks and years to come so stephen
go for it
yeah i'm
i'm really interested by the um
these different um
tying these bits together in a way i
suppose that sort of come up um we've
got
this sort of
information geometry that i suppose can
come from an ergodic space or a kind of
a state space
and then you've got solenoidal flows
within maybe an iso contour of that or
potentially i suppose it doesn't have to
be solenoid or it could be like an iso
contour
flow if it was more complex
and
when you've got that potential
to um
go and have a solenoidal type flow to
sample
would that be
um more a slightly more of a second
order
sampling approach that something might
use so you've got you know the
distribution could just emerge from a
steady space steady state sort of
ergodicity process and you would maybe
somehow
systematize a flow or way of engaging
that information and i could i could
imagine that would then
make sense of some of the entropy
entropy consuming potential of a living
system which is that it can kind of
go upgrade in descent and
the solenoidal flow then
gives scott's
sort of entropy secreting option it
seems a bit more viable then because
maybe i could choose
multiple solenoidal samplings
of
information geometries and
secrete the ones which aren't as good if
that makes sense so um so i'll be
curious in terms of how
you know that this the ability to go to
more second order
understandings within a system
um and within the dynamics might be
offered by
um
the solenoid or sampling maybe even
taking into account things like the the
landscape used on the um
the mountain car
um
problem you know that landscape if you
can't sample the whole landscape
ergodically could you have lots of
solenoidal
samples or something like that around
the landscape
yeah um
yeah it's a really good point so there's
deep connections between so you know
flow and information geometry
and mostly in the context of the as you
pointed out the sampling literature
so in um
so the the idea is that if you start a
stochastic process somewhere
and you have solenoidal flow
it will converge to its steady state a
lot faster than if it didn't have
solenoidal flow
so then you can quantify that in terms
of uh information geometry maybe taking
a shorter path to the steady state
um and things like that
um
so then there's also um a really nice
new paper actually called um
is there is there an analog of nesteroff
acceleration for mcmc
and so that that paper shows that
um
yes
that paper really like does a nice job
of illustrating some some deep
connections between
uh stochastic processes and information
geometry and so the idea is that if you
start with a very simple um called a
very simple process called overdumped
knowledge of dynamics
then you can show that um
actually the the dynamic
in information space
is doing um so like the process is doing
a gradient descent on kl divergence
um to reach to reach the the steady
state so the target distribution
so this is just this process is exactly
doing like standard standard variational
inference
but then if you add some solenoidal flow
you actually
make that convergence happen faster so
it's like an accelerated method
and so and so in terms of biology you
can say that if you have solenoidal flow
um your inference happens faster so
you're like uh
you're able to infer things a lot faster
so you like in a sense more intelligent
i think we talk about it in in one of
the figures
in in the part of the paper
and so and so in that paper that i just
mentioned
uh they showed that with a particular
stochastic process
actually
implement some kind of
accelerated variational inference
um
so yeah there's some literature about
that and it would be interesting to see
uh those processes that perform
inference very fast
whether when we put them in the bayesian
mechanics contest whether we can say oh
these actually
can be seen to correspond to
to biological systems that we've been
studying things like that
okay i just asked one quick question on
that
when you say add in solenoidal flow
is that adding it in the sampling
methodology or is it somehow maybe i
suppose it's a bit could it be thought
of physically or is that
how does that work
yeah definitely so the the sony nodal
flow is really this time irreversible
part
um so so
intuitively it's this kind of like
stirring or mixing the system so maybe
if you have um
a really nice example actually is if you
have a cup of coffee
and you and you pour milk in it
now what you could do
is just wait for the milk and the coffee
to mix together
and this would be no solenoidal flow
because you're not mixing anything like
it's just happening on its own and you
have a dynamic like in the in the figure
that we saw before like on the bottom
left so it would be time reversible
and this would like actually converge
the steady state pretty slowly so in
terms of information geometry you would
have a slow dynamic to the steady state
in terms of statistics you would have a
slow variation of inference because you
reach your target distribution very
slowly
now what you can do is adding in
solenoidal close so this would be i take
my spoon and i'm going to
stir the coffee and the milk together
then we all know then
that this is going to allow
the system to mix
and to and to
actually become uniformly mixed a lot
faster
so so mathematically
it means that we reach the target
distribution of the steady state faster
so the information geometry we're also
faster in terms of statistics
you can interpret that as doing
variational inference faster
now this interesting thing about adding
in solenoidal flow
is that um
in physics it's called breaking detail
balance
and breaking detail balance is about um
you actually probably need to to input
from entered input energy from the
outside
um so so this is the physical meaning of
the time irreversible part of the
dynamic
when when there is sometimes
irreversible part it means that the
there is
actually energy coming in from the
outside
and and this is also like um it ties in
nicely with biological systems we know
that biological systems consume energy
from the outside
so we know that they have to be
that they need to have some kind of
this irreversible dynamic
thanks lance so
anyone else in the live chat who wants
to ask a question this would be a good
time to go for it and then dean
and then anyone else
let's be gentle on me what i'm about to
put out there is i just feel really
vulnerable but i'm gonna throw it out
there anyway so
lots of chat chatter about the encoded
aspect of this and i think we all kind
of understand what that means
so
i'm gonna i'm gonna raise a metaphor
kind of a
around negative space and the idea of
threading a needle
which is if you think about it as a just
as a distributive exercise is plenty
complex like there's a lot of math in
terms of being able to just do that
thing that's that's hard hard enough
so
if i'm trying to explain to somebody
else a bayesian manifold and what that
represents
can i say that it's both a barrier and a
filter at the same time can i say that
it acts kind of like a sieve
meaning
meaning that it's mathematical structure
kind of acts as a ground to the physical
things that we
are inferring are going on in the world
so i guess what i'm asking is is
statistical mechanics
serving
to
allow us to understand what negative
space is as a non-form
within all
as as part of all the forms that we're
seeing the edges of and
and having a liminal understanding until
we get to the very limits of what and
the high definition of what that means
so
does the statistical manifold allow us
to go in around and pass through zero it
doesn't allow us to reverse the spin of
the solenoidal
but it does allow us to get away from
zero and move closer to what the known
is
because
if i if we continue to kind of go back
and forth between the physical math and
the statistical math i know why we have
to kind of talk
both at once like we have to have two
hands to clap but i think it's i think
what ends up happening is
in this conversation the encoding and
the physical piece tends to dominate
and then and the non-physical stuff the
statistical stuff maybe that ground that
the statistical manifold
allows for it doesn't it hasn't maybe
been fully fleshed out
in a way that helps me
help explain it to other people who
aren't as far along in this journey as
you are and i'm hoping to get to a place
where i can
translate it for them so maybe you can
just talk to that a little bit about
what is the statistical manifold is it
just the hard stuff that we see or
should we be paying attention
to maybe the spaces between all of those
data points
right um
yeah so
that's a a really interesting and
actually a hard question to answer um
but just to start with the the easy part
the the statistical manifold
is the mathematical object
that that says these are all the beliefs
all the different beliefs that you could
hold about your environment right and so
as time
as time evolves and you're gathering new
information
your
what your brain is doing is moving on
this statistical manifold your beliefs
are changing
over time and then in terms of um
explaining it to people
so the
always the the way the way that i try to
explain it is that
this um this like in information talk um
things encoding
things
things encoding information about other
it's just a different description
of the world
so we have a description that that takes
like matter and waves and forces and
things like that and then we have a
different description that looks at
information
and i think these two descriptions
are equivalent
um it's just two different ways to talk
about the same thing
on the other hand this um
way of talking about the world in terms
of information flows and information
processing
i think
it might be more general in the sense
that instead of needing to have like
matter and
all these different concepts different
kinds of particles and it gets really
messy
maybe it would be possible to unify more
with the concept of information because
with information you can explain what a
photon is and what
what a proton is and and you name it so
so it would be more um
more unified and maybe more
mathematically simple at the end of the
day but that remains to be seen
um interestingly so so there's this guy
evolved from from uh the computational
engine evolved from alpha so
this guy this guy's actually a physicist
i didn't know that until very recently
but he
has been doing some really interesting
work over the past few years
working towards a theory of everything
that is based on the concept of
information so information and
computation is the
like the the thing he starts with
and i think he's managed to
um he basically postulates that the
that the um
the world
evolves in time
according to some kind of computation
that's recursively applied to itself
so
you you could think of it in terms of a
dynamical system but so it's a like the
way he thinks about it is a bit more
general but it would be like maybe
um you give a number to a program and
then the program outputs a number and
then so that would be one time step
and then you reapply the program to that
number that would be another time step
and so he can he
and so he postulates that the universe
works in that way
um it evolves um according to like
discrete steps
with a repeated program and the program
would be the laws of physics it's like
kind of an abstract informational way to
look at it
and so the
so yeah so he he makes this um this very
abstract approach to physics
and uh and and also very simple i mean
very kind of unified approach to physics
and i think he's managed to derive
approximations to the equations of
relativity
just with that so with a certain kind of
program i mean anyway he's been um
doing some really interesting
work trying to unify known physics with
the concept of information
and he's written a very nice uh
article like a blog post about it i
think if you
if you google like a wolfram theory of
everything you might you might come up
it might come up
um but yeah it's um
i mean it's not it's not technical i
mean it is technical somehow but it's
not like
there's no equations it's conceptually i
think conceptually hard what he does but
the way he explains it is nice
um
so yeah i think we're moving to this
kind of
information-based physics but doesn't
mean that the physics that we know with
matter and so on should be discarded
uh it's just like different different
levels to talk about it just like we
have
um psychology that talks about the brain
uh from a
like very overall perspective
and then we have like
yeah talking about like maybe biases uh
our biases decision making so that would
be one description of the world and then
we have
molecular dynamics that will look at the
brain from a very
um
from a basic molecular level
and and all these descriptions have to
fit together somehow
and i think depending depending on what
we're trying to ask uh
one description would be more fit than
the other so
if i'm studying a human psychology is
probably much more useful than molecular
dynamics
thanks lance one quick comment on the
information is it allows us to drop into
a mode of matter and organization as
information
um which is still within the objective
stance but also it allows us to model
ourselves and our beliefs and thinking
about them informationally about other
beliefs or about matter which is a way
of mathematically
complementing the relational stance
so it also moves us towards wolfram's
vision of what new science would look
like because we actually have
quantitative relational techniques that
help us deal with our uncertainty and
about the way that we interact with the
world actively
interfering and measuring and
manipulating
not just like us walled off as the
investigator trying to get to the most
exact
framing of a system so it's really
interesting developments so we have time
for some more questions so scott
and then after that we'll go to steven
so go ahead scott
a couple of little thoughts on that last
bit so that that
multiple dynamics that you were talking
about very interesting it got me
thinking about
that coast of england problem
from um fractals where if you measure
the coast of england with a one mile
yardstick versus a one inch yardstick if
it's a one inch yardstick the coast of
england is longer
right it's because you're measuring more
than nooks and crannies right in the
fractal uh coast so
that scale
dependence when you talk about the
dependency we see
nature and see biology through different
lenses
it's kind of interesting if we have a
unifying lens maybe you start to have a
fractal and scale independent
descriptors then we'll pop out of that
because you'll start to have things
that'll
anyway it feels like this skewer coming
at descriptions of systems as you were
saying from different in different ways
they're the same system ultimately and
so there'll be an interesting analysis
on the way in which they come together i
guess is that this one piece another
thing
the
mention about information and the um
that kind of wolfram idea that expansion
um one of the things i had a
conversation with a couple of um
astrophysicists and i was talking to
them about
um seth lloyd out of mit a part of his
book called programming the universe he
talks about
the idea that all interactions since the
big bang have increased exponentially
just the number the volume of
interactions
and
i was talking to somebody about it and
they said well
if the universe is made of information
then the exponential increase in
information maybe that's what dark
energy is we perceive dark energy that
expansion force as being
something but really what it is is the
universe expanding out exponentially
because it's made of information and so
something just to think about it kind of
leaps around there between physics and
information theory but there's um
that's one other piece of it and then
the other piece of it was this
idea the outside energy you were talking
about before the need for outside energy
one of the things that i've been fussing
around with is whether in fact and in
2013 i did a presentation mit called
entropy accounting
and then the year after they did
something called entropy engines and the
idea that was that was that in
information theory in carnot's equation
you need a hot and cold differential to
perform work
um carnot's equation those differentials
are identical to arbitrage differentials
you need for a market to perform to move
if there's no information differentials
you don't have trading in markets and so
one of the questions is
roger penrose wrote a book recently
about the time before the big bang what
he talks about is we have the yellow
light of the sun come in and the
infrared light go out we don't overheat
except for climate change and carbon
dioxide blankets
because the net energy gain is zero
right energy and energy otherwise we'd
overheat he said what we gain
is neg entropy because the yellow light
of the sun has a higher information
carrying capacity than the red light
that goes out plants construct
themselves from the yellow light of the
sun
create neg entropy and then we
now
projecting forward are now burning that
fossil fuel that stored up that neg
entropy and releasing disorder
in the form of
now climate change disorder
political and social disorder so where
i'm jumping around there is suggesting
that disorder
accounting
and entropy accounting when you have von
neumann and shannon's link of physics
and information and other links like we
have here
that maybe when we're talking about
entropy as disorder we can talk about it
not by analogy but direct application to
social contexts
and start to use information and
understand disorder in society and in
markets as uh amenable to the same kind
of math that we find in some of these
biological systems thanks just a few
thoughts
thanks scott lance if you want to add
anything
sure um yeah that was really interesting
and um yeah so
um i want to add actually that
uh all this um
the thing that we talk about about like
reality can be described at different
scales
and i think there's a nice extension to
this work that that speaks to that you
could
um if you look at a human i mean it's
composed of a lot of cells and each cell
has its own boundary and then these
cells form organs that themselves have
their own boundary so there's um
let's read this recursive aspect of like
markov blankets being assembled together
at different scales and i think um
i think it would be interesting
interesting to impact that because i
think that's how
biological systems are formed but also
societies are formed as collections of
multiple different individuals that are
themselves that themselves form
organizations that
um that talk to each other and form
together a society so it's really this
recursive aspect and
being able to hopefully use the same
kind of math to talk about all these
different aspects
and
and also i mean
people um it's true like a lot of people
in the past maybe 10 20 years maybe more
they've used the same kind of
dynamical models that we have in this
paper i mean so very very standard
models to
model for example interactions between
people
and in particular models of opinion
formation
so for example maybe let's say we're in
the us and some people are democrats
some of our republicans some cannot
really make their mind yet and so they
would talk to each other they would
interact
and then they would converge onto a
steady state
where some
yeah some some people would be die hard
democrats in that city state so they
would kind of stay in that area
some people would be die hard
republicans and some people would like
yeah fluctuate flock to it in the middle
um so
i i think we can use
i mean
this math about stochastic processes and
information is really the
um
yeah the the
ground i mean the
the
a good framework or useful framework to
to model many kinds of things
um
but then
i think what a lot of these models are
missing is really this belief based
aspect
so a lot of these models of opinion
formation there they just say oh i'm a
particle you're a particle and we
interact just like particles in physics
with interact
um so so it's quite simplistic um
so i think once you i mean uh things are
very small
maybe we can describe them in a very
simple way
um but as you as like marco blankets
self-organize at different scales and
actually
as you go to larger and larger scales
um
things become a lot more complex
and i would say maybe we are the scale
at which things are
most complex
or molecules tend to be quite simple we
tend to be quite complex and then if you
go up and up again
maybe to planets
then things start to become really
simple again
because all these random fluctuations
are kind of average average doubt and
then we have newtonian mechanics where
everything kind of looks deterministic
so i think there's this like
sweet spot we're in where we're not too
big and not too small
and interesting things happen there
um
and that's where i would say that's
where i would say bayesian mechanics um
is hoping to fit in
in terms of uh explaining and describing
what's going on
cool so stephen go for it
yeah
that that um that idea again that brings
us back to embodiment i suppose because
we're embodied at
a particular size and scale and
um they sort of say if you go right down
to the smallest scale
of like and then right up to the biggest
scale
we are kind of in the middle
um
ironically but so i was wondering how
sort of following on from what you're
saying and bringing in the computational
psychiatry piece that you sort of
alluded to to this is
if we if we say that we've got
everything that we perceive even the
physicality of the world
we actually only have access it through
information anyway even if we are
actually accessing the the true physical
world
so we've got this process of sense
making that we're doing to to make that
idea of what is our consensus reality so
if our kind of working space that we're
in is our consensus reality
what's interesting is that
with
psychology and social sciences
you can almost say psychology is a bit
like
the predictive processing
model of the world it's like these are
predicted ways that are out there
um that have been chosen as the models
within a particular sort of discrete
spaces
and those are externally managed so it's
like an externally managed
system entry percent there could be an
entry repeat secreting system where it
looks like there is although entropy is
not actually a substance to secrete per
se
and you could say that it's externally
managed information geometry that the
social science as well with the averages
and the psychometrics that they
reference to they're all sort of housed
out there in the world and you've kind
of got
the kind of what we see is our reality
in the phenomenology of our experience
is kind of the boundary but what
your work's doing and what computational
psychiatry does and which we're not able
to do without those tools
is it allows us to go into that
neurobiology
and the actual like the internal
internally managed
stochastical dynamics of our own models
so to speak so not the ones that we make
out there to be our perspective on
which we try and reduce free energy
around but just what is the models that
we're doing what you call entropy
consuming i we're actually
just swimming in that entropy and
finding the variations right
and so i'm curious like
that that that ability for this type of
work to
contribute
to a new kind of
um way of knowing about
what it is to be in the world and go
into our internal models rather than
be reliant on these external
psychological and social science models
what's your thoughts on
how this might link into developing that
that field
[Music]
so
so are you talking specifically about
the link between
all this physics and and the psychology
or or is your question a bit more
general um well maybe the the boundary
between the kind of
like the scales of basically the
boundary of going for externally making
models of the world and standard models
like psychologists are doing and social
sciences are doing and psychometrics and
the ability to actually go into our own
models our own phenomenological
neurobiological
models and just say okay what are the
dynamics
that are alive not what are and
how we how are we actually managing not
how do we manage our models of what we
think they are which is kind of what
happens in our kind of niche but we're
able to probe
our own phenomenology so i was wondering
how you see that tying into that
yeah um yeah that's a that's a really
good point
so so as you as you point out i mean
now models in like psychology and
and uh computational psychiatry i mean
they're driven by intuition they're
driven by by experiment
and they're driven also by your own
biases
um
and our observations about um
yeah patients who who suffer some some
kind of um
yeah some kind of let's say
schizophrenia
and so we know we know schizophrenic
patrons behave like this and like that
and so we try to create models that kind
of reproduce that
and then we try to
um to validate these models by saying oh
uh maybe i can simulate some kind of uh
action potentials of some neurons and
then i'm gonna check
whether actually these organisms that
i'm studying have this um
same kind of action potential the same
kind of
electrophysiological responses
um
so i think that
i mean i think that's really good um and
and the research is doing a lot of
progress
um
but then
this kind of work not not this paper but
this line of work
would be able to to like
go the i mean um
i mean it takes a different perspective
and would be able ultimately hopefully
to describe mathematically
um what thinking like a human is uh what
what is being human mathematically and
of course there won't be like a
definition of this is a human
but they would hopefully be in the
future a mathematical description of how
we make decisions
and what class of models are we
implementing to make sense of the world
and how can we characterize these models
in terms of and and hopefully um the
community will get to that through
through physical experiments but also
through like
just mathematical conceptualization
um i think using using mathematics you
can
you cannot get you cannot just get there
without any like kind of experiment but
you still can
[Music]
there's still quite a few constraints um
that we have on
that we know that that humans have looks
for example breaking detail balance um
creation of entropy all these things we
we know
we know humans satisfy like uh
i mean they have a lot of um
characteristics and we can incorporate
that in the physics and i think this
really constrains the model space
that then people in psychology can go
and look into
so it just feels like um
when you're digging a tunnel and
psychology would like kind of dig in one
way
and basic mechanics would be digging
from the other direction and at some
point
uh they will meet in the middle
hopefully um but i don't i don't think
they have met really yet and it will
take a while
awesome
um
what
a fun discussion and it's so cool how
this paper it's almost like there was a
few stairs
we we explored
some basic ways to frame
how
nodes on a bayesian graph insulate other
sets of nodes
and then how that conditional
independence can be finessed for these
increasingly developed and elaborated
networks that do
as we talked about
expectations over external states all
the way up to variational base and then
it's like we at the top or at the middle
of that staircase started taking it in a
lot of other directions so this was
really a fun discussion
just in the last few minutes
maybe we can
any and all of us think like what are we
gonna
continue working on for some of us
that's probably a research project
others that's
i don't know lunch or something else
just how are we going to keep on
learning about this
and
start to apply it in our own work or
research
so i have a really good question liz are
you working on um
the
next paper where you're going to
partition the external state space or
have you started or it's just like
clicking on a backburner somewhere
uh it's not cooking yet so so you can
uh you're more than welcome to to go
ahead and
and start plowing
it's at the farmers markets the
ingredients are still out there and dave
also raised in an email some really
interesting questions about other
partitionings
and um
basically philosophical threads that
might be translated into different
possible partitionings
within internal states or
other ways of partitioning because
it was the partitioning of the blanket
states from kind of one set of
blanketing states into incoming sensory
and outgoing action active states that
allowed for this perception as inference
action planning as inference
step
and it's not that that's the end game of
node partitioning
so there's so many ways that these
partitions can continue stephen
yeah i'm gonna be
i'm trying to see how i like that
analogy the two tunnels or whichever way
the maybe it's a whole load of like um
insect warrens or whatever it is trying
to meet and um so psychology and
bringing together some of these
processes so i'm going to try and bring
that together maybe more actually not so
much from a clinical perspective but
maybe more from a community psychology
and psychosocial psychosocial
methodologies that might be used so
um
i i'm going to be chewing on that as
best i can so maybe if i ever stuck it
might i might fire you an email if
that's okay
yeah um
there's many ways we can continue and
also i think all along our trails we
dropped a few little notes for some
other pieces that could come into play
if anyone else wants to raise their
jitsie hand
we can take a last thought
otherwise though just in closing lance
this was awesome and conor as well for
joining the first live stream this was a
great
uh development we all learned a ton so
i hope those watching live or in replay
also
got something out of this paper
you're always welcome back anytime you
want to jump on a guest stream or be a
participant just
always welcome
thank you so much daniel and thank you
everyone for the discussion i really
enjoyed it
okay
see everyone next time
thanks bye
[Music]
great times thanks everyone